as canada officially and publicly
announces it is getting back into the
business of training ukrainians to fight
there is a much more secretive mission
canada is involved in on the ground
multiple sources say elite canadian
operators from the canadian special
operations command are working in the
shadows to help train ukrainian troops
and facilitate weapons and equipment
delivery the minister of national
defense did not deny the reports but was
tight-lipped it would be imprudent for
me to provide that information today the
minister announced 225 canadian military
personnel will deploy to the united
kingdom working with the british army to
turn ukrainian civilians who have signed
up to fight russia into soldiers
it is the relaunch of operation unifier
the mission to train ukrainian troops
originally in ukraine that was suspended
just before russia attacked we are
fulfilling our promise to resume large
scale training
under operation unifier canadian troops
will start training their ukrainian
recruits with the basics everything from
frontline fighting skills to patrolling
weapons handling and first aid
imparting basic skills and generating
new recruits is critical because of the
type of war ukraine finds itself in the
ukrainians are in a war of attrition
with the russians and they are
sustaining very high casualties training
troops is something canada is
particularly skilled at these are
something that canada has particular
expertise in both within nato and sort
of around western allied countries
the past training from operation unifier
and similar allied programs have proven
worth their weight in gold in terms of
the skills and professionalism imparted
to ukrainian soldiers which took the
russian military by surprise
the first contingent of canadian troops
will come from 3rd battalion of princess
patricia's canadian light infantry based
in edmonton and will deploy next week
canadians have also been training
ukrainians already on how to use those
m7777 howitzer guns that canada has sent
over pharah mercedes-stevenson in ottawa
thank you mercedes